hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
in michelle foucault's essay
the subject and power he tells us quite
a lot about the trajectories and aims of
his overall research projects in which
he makes some pretty important
contributions within the realm of social
theory and arguably philosophy
particularly when it comes to our
understanding of how power works and
what power is but he starts off by
saying
my goal was not ultimately just to study
power relations or power as such the
topic of power it was to understand what
it means to be human subjects
and so studying power in power relations
is part of a bigger picture
what does he tell us about his his focus
on power relations and the study of
power
well
he says there's a lot of ways to go
about
examining this and then he says
i would like to suggest another way to
go further toward a new economy of power
relations a way that is more empirical
more directly related to our present
situation
and one that implies more relations
between theory and practice now this is
you know quite a lot of advantages so
let's look at each of these in turn a
way that is more empirical what does
that mean we can look at actual cases
and instead of immediately projecting
some sort of ideal
theory or matrix onto them we see what
they actually
reveal to us because we're talking about
human subjects who will
tell us all sorts of things about what's
going on some of them you know quite
false and ideologically motivated some
of them perhaps closer to something like
an ideal of truth but looking at what
actually is said done
enacted
all those sorts of things and then
this other advantage uh
implying more relations between theory
and practice
the goal of theorization is not just to
come up with a notion of what power is
so we can contemplate it in some
old-fashioned philosopher sense but
rather it's so that we can
do things with it so we can have
practices it's not quite like you know
marx opined at one point in time the
clearly false statement that
philosophers have been content to
interpret or to understand or to look at
the world now the goal is to change it
but there is some sort of connection
between those and it goes all the way
back
to thinkers like say aristotle or or
plato for whom
developing some understanding some grasp
on what's going on would inform what we
do what we choose what we pursue in the
present so how does this
how does this new analysis work he says
that
what we would do is take the forms of
resistance against different forms of
power as a starting point so
we we get to see what power is
not just by looking at how it's
exercised how it's justified how it's
understood by the powerful but the
resistances against it it's you know if
we want to use a metaphor here we're
sort of like seeing
by
throwing something out there into a room
that at least at this point is not
completely dark but is certainly in
shadow and we see what pushes against
the the thing that we're throwing there
maybe we poke a stick in there or
something like that right except in this
case somebody's already poked sticks and
we find people responding so he says to
use another metaphor we're using it like
a chemical catalyst so as to bring to
light power relations locate their
position find out their point of
application
quantum we in french you know where they
actually grip i like gripping point as a
way to translate that and the methods
that are used and
so you know this would not just be one
overarching thing like you know a lot of
people joke around about foucault that
he thinks everything is a prison
prisons would be one domain in which we
could we could do that we could look at
the disciplinary models and then how
people push back against them what
resistances they they have not just the
prisoners but perhaps also the
correctional officers and other people
in the prison system but then there's
also all sorts of other
things you know it's not quite true that
that the joke that foucault looks at
everything and sees a prison no there's
the the asylum which is not quite the
prison the workhouse which is something
different and if you were around today
he would probably be looking at the
modern corporation under late capitalism
and its permeation by all these other
things you know like
how
you know capital flows into it and
social media is used within it and all
sorts of other technology so
long story short he tells us rather than
focusing on the internal rationality
we
analyze power relations through the
antagonism of strategies and what does
that mean
again instead of sort of taking a
top-down what does the literature put
out by or the you know the official
statements put out by
those who have power and exercise it you
know examining it maybe going behind the
scenes a little bit and saying oh yeah
we know what the real logic is here
we want to do something that's a little
bit more piecemeal and see
how people push back
antagonism is the the you know fighting
the conflict
and they are often strategies even
though they may not be explicitly worked
out strategies
so foucault tells us then and he gives
us a listing here that's quite
interesting
we're going to look at these features
before that he says
in order to understand what our society
means by sanity maybe we need to
investigate what's happening in the
field of insanity what we mean by
legality in the field of illegality in
order to understand what power relations
are about maybe we should invest the
forms of resistance and attempt made to
dissociate these relations so he says as
a starting point then let's take a
series of oppositions that have
developed over the last few years now
he's writing this you know decades back
so what are these opposition to the
power of men over women we can call this
you know the movement of feminism and
feminist critique right
and and that would also include the
power
women also privileged women exercise
over other women and we could make it
much more complicated as well but that's
that's one that's still with us right
parents over children
that that's another one that's been
going on psychiatry over the mentally
ill
nowadays we would not just say
psychiatry we would say psychiatry
psychology counseling you know the
mental health
industry and and all of that
medicine over the population
administration over the ways people live
and we could add further ones to this
and we might think about whether the
ones we would add in the present
would have these six characteristics
that foucault is going to lay out for us
so he says these are not just
anti-authority struggles it's not just
like screw authority down with it they
all have some some
qualities or features in common
so what are they
now this is a very interesting one the
first one that he notes
they are transversal struggles meaning
that they're not limited to one
country and he says of course they they
can develop you know more easily and to
a greater extent in certain countries
but they're not confined to a particular
political or economic
form of government so if we think about
you know the various liberation
or rights or equality
movements
they aren't just located just in america
or just in brazil or just in india now
there will be some
that are um you know really very local
and and
getting most of their notice just within
that
particular framework but
i would say today even more so because
of the
capacity for
news and journalism
and social media to penetrate
you know worldwide
this transversality is even more
pronounced
the second one
is that they as he says they target
power effects as such
so
he uses the medical profession as an
example the medical profession is
criticized
not primarily because it's a profit
making concern
but because it exercises an uncontrolled
power over people's bodies their health
and their life and death and you know
you could say well
actually in a lot of cases we are
criticizing
how they're making their money and you
know turning people here in the united
states is maybe unfamiliar to people
worldwide um
here in the united states we don't have
a health care system we have this
incredible patchwork of much of it for
profit and you know with highly inflated
prices for for uh the the equipment
being used and hospitals billing people
in all sorts of crazy ways turning over
accounts to collection agencies there is
you know this this vast complex that you
can say but it's not an a system as such
and a lot of people are criticizing it
precisely because it is so much about
making money and also about liability
but you can say well what's what's the
telos what is the
greater purpose
that is being complained about
it's not producing health or if it is
it's producing health at the expense of
other things at the expense of say
personal freedom
you know and so we could go on and on
with other examples but let's look at
the next one
he also says
these are immediate struggles and he
puts it into quotes for two reasons
what are the two reasons in such
struggles people criticize instances of
power that are the closest to them
they don't look for the chief enemy but
the immediate enemy so they're not
if we want to use the uh you know
example coming from
uh anti-american and also anti-soviet
stuff we don't just look at the the
great satan we look at the one who's
right there uh governing and keeping
people from being able to to exercise
their their
religious liberties or things like that
in middle eastern countries where you've
got like a strong man setting up you
know in a dictatorial government that's
actually quite cruel to the people
so
you know
this is something that's really
important
a lot of times social movements get
bogged down because people will be like
you know don't worry about the local
thing man
there's this bigger system and we gotta
like change the whole thing and a lot of
people you know ordinary people
generally are like no man i want to
focus on what's actually in front of me
i want to focus on let's say it's
policing i want to focus on the dirty
cops in in my environment and not just
on policing in general and trying to
bring the department of justice in i
want to actually produce some change
here or if it's about you know doctors
and medical complexes i want to focus on
this health care provider and what
they've been doing and and why it's
wrong
so you know that's one sense of
immediate
and then he says nor do they expect to
find a solution to their problem and a
future date that is liberation's
revolutions end-of-class struggle
they are looking for some change
in the present it doesn't have to be
utopian change but they want to see
something
happening
so those are three important features
and then foucault goes on he says
these are not the most original points
meaning that there'd be a lot of other
things that would have these in common
as well
instead he says the following to me
seemed more specific
so we're getting closer to the heart of
what he's after
he says
they are struggles that question the
status of the individual
what does he mean by that he says they
assert the individuals assert the right
to be different and underline everything
that makes individuals truly individual
on the other hand these struggles
attack everything that separates the
individual breaks their links with
others splits community of life forces
the individual back on themselves and
ties them to their own identity in a
constraining way so it's really about
the meaning of individuality
whether people realize it or not
that's what's what's being enacted
according to foucault
and he goes on and he says these are not
for or against the individual as such
there's struggles against the government
of individualization
so
you know what does that mean
well there's certain ways there's
there's individuals and then there's
individualization where you can be sort
of
ratified as an individual this way is
okay this way is not okay and government
does get in fact involved in that so you
know when we go and get a driver's
license for example
we are participating in one of these
sort of
governmentalities of individualization
you might say oh that's pretty innocuous
well yes but it ties you in with all
these other things
as well we use driver's licenses for all
sorts of
other tasks it's a form of id that we
have to present at certain points
getting a driver's license involves a
whole certification process right
so he goes on and he says okay there's a
fifth feature
their opposition to the effects of power
linked with knowledge competence and
qualification
struggles against the privileges
of knowledge so that's an interesting
feature as well we always have the
people who are established as not
necessarily experts but let's call them
the the string pullers the practitioners
the ones who actually get to decide and
it could just be that they happen to be
in hr and they've taken a few you know
seminars that if you looked at them in
an educational way it's all this is
really garbage stuff but they're
certified they're the one who gets to
decide whether you fill that form
properly or not they are gatekeepers
and
so it's a struggle against them but it's
also a struggle against
another
issue of knowledge he says
they are an opposition against secrecy
deformation and mystifying
representations imposed on people
people want to know what's actually
going on
you know the lingo that you're using
what does it actually mean
bureaucrats or
ceos or whoever else is the person who
is being talked about and they want more
transparency now he says there's nothing
scientistic in this adult that is a
dogmatic belief in the value of
scientific knowledge
but neither is it a skeptical or
relativistic refusal of all verified
truth what is questioned
is now here's the way the foucault
frames it the way in which knowledge
circulates and functions its relation to
power and we might reframe this in terms
of who actually gets access to the
knowledge and who doesn't and how the
how the knowledge gets transferred you
might think about the issue that's
that's come up today
uh not not just in when i say today i
mean in in the current present that we
inhabit
about police wearing their cameras and
recording what's going on and keeping
those cameras on it's not so simple as
well a a police person does something
shady questionable brutal and then we
say okay let's let's check the film
because you have to go and you have to
apply for it and some police departments
have figured out well the way to make
people not do that is you charge them a
lot of money for that and say well we're
respecting other people's privacy it has
to be redacted
these are all strategies by the powerful
and people who don't have power are
pushing back against this
you know and we could go on and on with
all sorts of other examples
here's where we get to the most
interesting thing and and where it
becomes very directly philosophical he
says
all these present struggles revolve
around the question
who are we
it's a question of
identity who are we
who are we as individuals
who am i as this individual
also who are we
as this
group or community or whatever else is
connecting us together
he says
these struggles are a refusal of these
abstractions of economic and ideological
state violence
which ignore who we are individually and
also a refusal of scientist scientific
or administrative inquisition that
determines who one is and we could
probably add to that and i think if
foucault were around in the present
sort of a commercial or corporate uh way
of of imposing identity on people as
well and so this is this is uh these are
all central
aspects of these recent oppositions
he goes on and
he also says that
the main objective of these struggles is
to attack
not so much such and such an institution
of power group or elite or class
but rather a technique a form of power
that might seem to go a little bit
against the
immediacy of it
and i think what we have to assume here
is that foucault thinks that this is
what's going on behind the scenes even
though people are articulating their
responses in an immediate way in
relation to to you know what he's just
talked about an institution a pow
a group an elite a class
so he says what is the form of power
we're talking about
he says the form of power that applies
itself to immediate everyday life
categorizes the individual
marks them by their own individuality
attaches them to their own identity
imposes a law of truth on them that they
must recognize and others have to
recognize in them
it is a form of power that makes
individuals subjects so we're looking at
what he's going to call subjection
here
that's the the form that or the the
technique of power that is being in some
way resisted i'm you know if we want to
put it in really basic stuff i'm not the
form that you have in front of you on
the computer that details you know what
i am i'll give you a private example of
you know one of my own experiences with
this you know i've been teaching uh for
20 years teaching online for eight years
and one of the institutions that i work
for very very bureaucratic
and in some respects dysfunctional it's
it's not particularly well set up and
they have a certification office
who i had to like get all these forms of
you know where i've taught and you know
just to prove that i actually have the
the time in teaching i mean it wouldn't
be hard for them to look it up just
doing a little bit of google searching
right especially in my case since a lot
of it's been filmed but you got to go
through their procedures and the people
in the office know that their procedures
are cumbersome and don't make sense
and yet they're like yeah but you got to
do it and they don't want to hear you
saying
this this can't we like work out
something more reasonable and and
there's there's things like that that we
encounter over and over and over again
now notice what's going on there i'm not
just doing something purely external to
me i'm doing something that that
characterizes me as the individual who i
am as somebody who is fit to enter their
classrooms virtually or physically and
teach classes something that the people
running the mechanism of power
know zero about
right
and we could come up with all sorts of
other examples but let's close on on
what he he says here
something that clarifies what we mean by
subject he says there's two meanings of
the word subject one is
subject to someone else by control and
dependence
right so i am subject to somebody i am
somebody's subject
and we can think about when we're
looking at the what he's calling the
scientific or administrative inquisition
i am i am being subjected in the sense
like i'm a bug under the microscope or a
human being under the scrutiny right
the other is
tied to a person's own identity
by a conscience or self-knowledge by
agency we could say by deciding for
oneself so on the one hand we have
subject as
determined controlled
surveilled on the other hand we have
subject as
responsible as able to choose to to to
decide what to do having some reflexive
self-knowledge relation to the self and
he says that
both meanings suggest a form of power
that subjugates and makes subject to so
through your own agency you get caught
up in this this power and he says that's
part of
what we're reacting against and that's
what we can study in studying
power
you